[Music]
okay so you you have this this final
awakened and you write this thing then a
year later I think in 86 you wrote why
it was it why I left last I wrote an
essay look I I say I I was personally
threatened by Elaine brown and then I
have the tape of the phone conversation
[ __ ] if you if you should get run over
David really I'm I'm going to be your
best friend because people will say I
did it something like that I mean it
with a naked threat so I was afraid I
said to kate Coleman wrote an article
for a now-defunct left-wing magazine
what's called the party's over about the
criminality of the Panthers which I had
discovered by personal investigation for
the UH I forgot well getting to the
Village Voice piece Oh the Village Voice
yeah so I finally in 1986 which is it's
a decade later I wrote a piece why I am
not no longer leftist and and referred
to this I did not name the killers but I
did refer to the murder and the pant
that the Panthers had murdered her and a
Paul Berman wrote this piece about the
renegade Horowitz the intellectual life
and the renegade Horowitz I was a
vicious attack and he had me at the end
of his piece cheering on sulla Sita who
was a psychopath
that was a contra in Nicaragua whom I
hadn't even heard of when he called me
said and Horowitz is cheering wakes up
and I got wanting cheering so Mussina so
basically you you went off the
reservation officially with this article
and then you said the knives were
already out well then no is with the
reagan article yeah with the regular
article I realize this is right this is
right
left right so this was he was a year
later I think was 85 and 86 so a year
later so the knives already added then
this was like sort of the final door on
that's right and that's not 1986 87
that's like 30 years ago is I what it is
from that like that in 30 years my work
has never been taken the work the the
ideas my arguments with the left why I
know why what a long essay on leaving
the left and why I left it never
responded to and the nation made one
stay about it but not a very good one on
the other hand there's like a hundred
thousand attacks on me I mean and some
leftist so it's not like they don't
think that I need to be refuted I think
it's just more effective to them
pretending well if it makes you feel any
better right before we sat down I was
scrolling my Twitter feed and some
article was written about me where they
referred to me at the right winger and
then got a few other things incorrect
about me and then my own audience
actually started attacking them on
Twitter and then they they didn't issue
a retraction but they change the
headline at least and change one other
thing which of course is not
journalistically sound but I guess maybe
I'm picking up some of it well at first
it hurts but eventually you get to be
liable proof they libel you so much that
it just means ridiculous more than
anything else it's just lazy lazy and
read out well you know you know army
easier target than you are because I
vowed when I left the left that I'm
going to talk to the left address them
in the same way that they address
everybody else know how I hate them
nicely yeah you look very good very hard
to demonize yeah I'm so amazing
so when you see you in who had some nice
things to say about me when you sat down
when you see someone like me that
understands the title of this book and
understand your journey and all that do
you think I was just even though I'm
obviously art we have 35 years between
us that I was just late to the game and
picking up what was going on here or do
you think something also happened in the
last couple of years with the last I
think yeah I think you're too worried
all starting with the McGovern campaign
that's when it started the Communists
left infiltrated and took over the
Democratic Party in Tom Hayden who is no
longer with us was a cynical
anti-american lying radical and he was
given the Medal of Freedom by Bill
Clinton he was a state legislator in the
state of California you can still see
his work whenever you see prop 65 that
warns you about the bad effects of
chemicals in your whatever yeah it's
everywhere here in LA yeah but the
Democratic Party took the left in the
the Anna and the NI American
totalitarian and I would say racist left
I will explain that the Atlanta got
racist left was taken into the bosom of
the Democratic Party in the Clinton
administration and with Obama they got
one of theirs in the White House okay so
let's pause there for a second so when I
hear you heard about the Clinton
administration that's hard for me to
picture because those eight years were
basically I don't think we saw a lot of
what we're seeing right now so what am I
missing
well you must even know the
personalities for one I've written a
literally I think back to the Clinton
issues are very fondly still that things
were basic or the return that they were
basic rule unless Clinton Bill Clinton
was not an ideologue in the way that
Hillary Clinton is Bill Clinton's
physiology was walk that it was a zippy
odd and but that you would argue that's
probably saving grace then yeah you know
corruption is far better than communist
yeah but it could burn for the
corruption of the Clintons Bernie
Sanders what a pin a nominee huh that's
a great quote there she should be just
corruption is far better than communism
it'll it is it is because you've got to
mean that you can deal with it doesn't
have to
geology that sweeps people along with it
Bill Clinton domestically was a fairly
centrist you know not too much to
quarrel with him there on foreign policy
was terrible absolutely terrible the
World Trade Center was blown up in not
1993 by ramzi yousef he intended to kill
50,000 people or 200,000 a top of one of
the towers on the other the bomb is
fired it wounded a thousand people and
killed six Bill Clinton never visited
the site dismissed it as an individual
criminal act when it was inspired by the
blind Sheik has just been a farmer bin
Laden we should have been stopped in the
90s before the World Trade Center was I
can't go on written a lot about this so
bill but in the case of that in case the
first World Trade Center bombing so what
do you think was going on in Bill
Clinton's head went so this happened he
never visited him what is what's the
ideology there that would lead him to
that it's an interesting question I wish
we had one of these Democrats on and you
can ask them the question um I'll try to
get a former I am consider to skip ahead
in this book I've written big agenda I I
lay out what I think is going on that
Democratic Party is now a racist party
you use the phrase people of color is a
racist phrase identity politics is
racist and it's anti-american the
fundamental American idea is that we're
all creatures of a divinity or may be
nature's God whatever Jefferson wrote
there and equal in the eyes of our
Creator therefore we should be treated
equally by our government and we have
rights that are inalienable that
government can't take away so it's all
about individual freedom and most
importantly individual accountability
when I was a kid
and public schools we always does this
phrase regardless of race color or creed
an American is somebody who doesn't look
at your origins we're a nation of
immigrants that way don't look at your
origin of course if you come from a
terrorist country language I've ever
bedding is a little betting process yeah
identity politics is the opposite but
the left seeks that we are in a civil
war situation now and the reason is the
reason it's so irreconcilable is that
the left believe is racist that believes
in a racial hierarchy so if you're the
right skin color which is dark you go to
the head of the line for admissions to
college go to the head of the line for
job you go to the head of line for a
promotion you're going to have a line
for almost anything everything is not
diverse enough so we'll take anybody so
what would you say to the people that
would say well white people had a good
for a long time and yeah and white
people honor does it have things and
they did good things one of the good
things that white America did was to
liberate the slaves
people forget that we inherited slavery
this is our day myself notorious on the
left by coming out against reparations
for slavery a hundred and thirty seven
years after the fact America inherited a
system of slavery slavery existed I
learned this from Orlando Patterson who
is a black left-of-centre sociologist at
Harvard has written
prize-winning books on slavery and
freedom slavery exist at RIT 3,000 years
nobody ever said it was immoral not
Jesus not Moses not Aristotle until a
white Christian males in England led by
Wilberforce said it's immoral and an
American slave owner Thomas Jefferson
wrote it into the birth certificate of
this country that all men are created
equal and a given right to liberty by
their creator
within 20 years the slave trade was
ended the reason that America didn't
initiate a civil war in 1776 to free the
slaves what are the biggest reason was
that England going to come and just
retaking the colonies and reinstituted
slavery anyway and within a generation
or a little more given in those days
people lived shorter life at the cost of
three hundred and fifty thousand Union
soldiers we liberated slaves and
liberated them throughout the hemisphere
so black people Americans can be very
proud of their heritage you know it's
it's a human heritage so it's got a lot
of dance spots but you look at any other
country in the world and forgive me
Leptis for saying there's something nice
about America is the best what other
country do Asians get in both and risk
their lives to get into you think
they're coming here to be oppressed
right I mean everybody everybody 100 to
be here and then the funny thing is this
at the same time you go to swatch some
of these protests and the people that
are screaming about how racist and evil
and patriarchy and all this stuff
they're also doing calling for open
borders they want everyone to share in
the horror that is well I would go to
destroy the country and then anybody
with any sense knows so how you solved
it let me just say yeah the left is is
it owes whatever ideas it has to Marx
it's the Marxist paradigm of the
oppressors and the oppressed and it's an
economic begins as an economic and
they've layered on race and gender so
the fact is what determines a country's
prosperity culture not classes its
culture America has a great culture we
take in one of the things we do is we
take in brilliant people from all over
the world and give them freedom to
innovate other countries copy our
innovations Israel is the same way it's
why they hate it because they're
bringing in people
all over the women even a migraine but
but also it's the freedom yeah people do
not appreciate freedom in this country
obviously since we are universities are
now totalitarian institutions I can't go
to a university without bodyguards yeah
and that's the truth for the last 15
years I've been physically attacked if I
didn't have bodyguards in at the
universities put in place security I
could never get to a speech yeah and I'm
not alone it's any concern no it's a
virtually any conservative and it's and
now it's moderates and is fascism and
that's it's totally embedded in our
university system yeah do you make a
distinction between sort of the leaders
who really understand the stuff that
you're talking about so the people who
are the leaders of this leftist movement
versus the bulk of the people who I
think are following along without bad
intentions like when I see all these
kids why I you know I mock them already
people got a demonstration to get laid
yeah yeah you know and people are
gullible and they don't think and they
can't put two and two together the
phrase I didn't want to skip this people
of color yes a racist phrase it's not
English do we say here's a box of
crayons of color in French that's the
way French people think totally the
color whatever they say yeah so it's a
completely ideological construct so what
is its function well let's look at the
Mexico two main ethnic groups the
descendants of the Spanish conquistadors
who slaughtered the indigenous Indians
and the descendants of the indigenous
Indians when they cross the border
they're both people of color therefore
they're oppressed both of them the
conquistadors and the indigenous people
they're oppressed they deserve special
sensitivities and special privileges
Maharaja's in India are people of color
be headers in raqqa are people of color
who are people of color
white people yeah white people are evil
this is opposes this is the racist
ideology of our time is it also lacking
in several other ways I mean for example
you could take American Indian people
who moved here from India or their
grandparents moved here from India or
you could take Asian people of virtually
any nationality and they don't count in
this leftist thing because they deserve
it economically well the Indians haven't
yeah the Native Americans I'm sorry no
that was a particularly I hope now gonna
we're not gonna edit that out because I
don't believe in that but it was a
completely idiotic thing amen and I mean
American Indians from India who moved to
America Native American correct yeah
correct
Chinese Japanese American Indian that
need America Thank You penny that's
correct
yeah I just ruined course I don't like
to see you that's mine are yes you know
don't look over your shoulder yeah
there's only error
there's only arrows coming now India
joke right there I mean the left is
pathetic intellectually they don't have
an argument so they have to purge those
groups because those groups you know
that's why they have to shut you up
because I can't deal with your arguments
is really simple straightforward and and
it's so invaded on literary culture the
last two National Book Awards were given
to racist tracks one by tiny easy coats
I can never remember the title was it
just a ranked racist coats what what
inspired him to write the book it's
about how evil America is but that was
the murder of his friend not the burnish
the killing of his friend by a policeman
in Maryland it turns out as he tells you
that the policeman at the policeman
accused the dead his dead friend of
trying to run him over with his car the
policeman is black so I what does God
say he was thinking white now if
Tennyson to pure huh racism and this one
now is called stamp from the beginning
it's a semi-literate book
that they have lowered their standards
and so dramatically as a it still shocks
me because these are intelligent people
that people give the awards but I should
know better but it opens with the police
shootings of criminals in the last year
which were totally distorted by black
lives matter and other leftist into cops
gunning down unarmed blacks these were
predators and who did they prey prey on
they preyed on black people Freddie gray
I mean you know you could go on I can't
even remember the names a guy in
Ferguson they're criminals who prey on
black people but this guy has them as
innocent blacks who have gunned down by
racist cops so at the opening of his
book which is but which he has called
the definitive history of racism in
America he's exposed as a liar
anyone a National Book Award so our
institutions have been just generally
corrupted yeah so what is my this racist
ideology of the left so for a lot of
people hearing this I think a certain
amount of people here in this room
though yeah I get it so you don't talk
quite like this which is why I think of
much honor to uh
I want to see you with a so-called
liberal I don't call them liberals got
their bigots yeah well I've had many
progressive progressives on this show
and I treat them with the same respect
that I treat anybody else
I did my general rules I don't find that
berating somebody or belittling them but
yeah I made this Bell ready 30 years ago
then I was going to break the left I was
gonna say hey LBJ how many kids did you
kill today I actually when I was still
sort of leaving the left I thought about
that statement a lot saying let's see if
I were a prisoner of war and I was in a
room with my captor what I rather it was
LBJ or Ho Chi Minh and it was a
no-brainer so that's part of it is that
you just constantly say the worst thing
about your
we'll opponent because there's no end
here that you just couldn't write a lot
us constantly say anything to you and
that's where I love my loaf because it
just throws it right back in their face
and that's what really needs to be done
these people need to be embarrassed
alone probably beyond embarrassment yeah
I mean ABC News Stephanopoulos is
sitting there with Katrina vanden Heuvel
whose entire life has been spent
apologizing for defending and advancing
communist causes that was that that's
ABC that's how far gone this country is
[Music]
you